I've been using the iPhone se two ever
since it launched and it's honestly
surprised me in multiple ways we all
knew that this phone is gonna be a great
value and that Apple is gonna sell a ton
of them but there were many things that
I didn't expect which I'll share in this
video and it's actually gonna change my
iPhone habits going forward I'll also
share two reasons why I'm going back to
my 11pro but these reasons might not
matter to you let's start out with the
first thing that I loved and that is the
size man as this thing feels so good in
the hand now I know that this is
basically just an iPhone 8 and this
shouldn't be a surprise but I've been
using huge iPhones ever since the 6 plus
6s plus 7 plus and so on all the way to
my 11 Pro max I've often heard from the
crowd that hates large phones that they
will not upgrade until they get a new
small phone and honestly I thought they
were being a bit too dramatic the iPhone
se and the 8 can't be that much smaller
than a 10 R or an 11 right well once
you've used them side-by-side like you
did in the comparison and especially if
you're used to a smaller phone the
difference is quite noticeable going
from the 11 Pro max to the 8 is crazy
and even though I miss the big screen
the phone was so comfortable in the hand
it almost made the small screen worth it
unfortunately even though so much of
this phone is from the iPhone 8 Apple
dropped 3d touch which I loved
I expected to be disappointed having to
go back to touch ID after using face ID
for so many years but man is it quick
and in times like these where I am often
using a mask touch ID works way better I
also found it faster to raise the phone
and swipe left to open the camera app
then to use the new long press on the
camera icon pulling up for the control
panel was so much easier than pulling
from the top on IMAX
and not having topped awake did suck at
first but then I just pressed the button
if I wanted to see notifications for
example if the phones on my desk the one
thing that I definitely really missed
was the super fast app switching by
sliding my fingers across the bottom bar
on the new phones the speakers are
better than I expected
getting really close to the much larger
iPhone 11 but just like the iPhone 8 and
10 the earpiece speaker is still quieter
than on the newer phone
so if you're watching videos it does
seem a little bit out of balance having
more sound coming from the bottom firing
speaker
[Music]
I definitely think that Apple could have
made a few small improvements like the
earpiece speaker but I also understand
why they didn't because they really
wanted to hit that 399 price point and
spend the extra money on other things
another thing that wasn't upgraded were
the cameras now everybody expected that
se to have the same exact cameras as the
iPhone 10 are and the 10s but that's
actually not true we first found this
out in our comparison where the selfie
camera could only record 1080p at 30
frames per second where the 10r could do
1080p 60 and the 11 could do 4k 60 this
was really odd and the only explanation
was that Apple kept the same
front-facing camera as in the iPhone 8 a
few days later iFixit published their
teardown and I was very surprised that
the rear camera is also from the 8th
meaning it is really old in terms of
text since the last two years brought
major upgrades with larger faster
sensors now what surprised me even more
than that was how good the photos looked
there was a huge difference in photo
quality going from the iPhone 8 to the
10r when we tested them but the old
sensors in the SE are now taking
noticeably better photos than the 10 are
in the 10s the dynamic range is better
details better and even noise is lower
this just shows how much software and
processing matters for photos and Apple
definitely knew that when they put the
same a 13 Bionic processor in this $400
phone that's in my $1100 iPhone 11 Pro
max because of it the SE has a new smart
HDR tech and in good lighting the images
look as good as the iPhone 11 Pro which
is crazy in lower lighting the 11 looks
better due to deep fusion tech which
isn't possible due to the slower sensor
and the same thing goes with night mode
which is a bummer with that said in
pretty much every case the SE beats out
the iPhone 10s and 10 R which logically
doesn't make sense because the hardware
is older but it does I went ahead and
set up a blind photo comparison that I'm
gonna have Vadim do so if you want to
see the SE stack up against these other
iPhones and if you want to see if a team
actually tell a difference make sure you
guys are subscribed then you have
notifications enabled after testing it
out my view of the SE is much better
than it was before and I think that most
people that have older iPhones are gonna
be extremely happy with it at $399 for a
64 gigabyte model I can see so many
people who are hanging on to dying
iPhones finally upgrading I can also see
a lot of people upgrading from budget
Android phones both old ones and new
ones in finally getting an iPhone
because of the really low price and that
in turn is gonna make Apple a lot of
money on services down the line now my
two biggest complaints were the lack of
the ultra wide lens and the telephoto
which I love and use all the time and
the battery life now I use my phone all
the time which is why I love the iPhone
11 Pro max which has a massive battery
but thankfully from the comparisons I've
seen online the new S II actually can
get about an hour extra screen on time
compared to the iPhone 8 thanks to that
new a 13 processor and of course the S
II does support fast charging they have
to buy afterwards Apple's costs a lot
but I have a link in the video
description to a charger that is
certified and comes with a cable for
only $17 altum Utley I am going back to
my iPhone 11 pro max but you can count
on me finally breaking my huge iPhone
trend that has been going on for many
years and next time around going for a
smaller iPhone all thanks to trying out
the new iPhone se thank you guys for
watching let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below click that
little circle above if you guys want to
see our full review of the S key and if
you want to see the comparisons we have
somewhere right over there this has been
maxed and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]